>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D. C.
>>Mark Dimunation: So
welcome back to Rare Book
and Special Collections
Division everyone.
We're very excited
about today's talk.
Glen Emil is a collector
and a donor to the Library
of Congress the collection that
you're hearing about today.
The Edward Gorey Collection
now resides in this division.
It was a wonderful gift that came in
last year and it also came with Glen
who now resides in our
division on a regular basis.
He's not only an expert collector
that brought in 800 pieces
of Goreyana but is also a compiler
of the Goreyography his online
bibliography of Gorey pieces
so he brings a great
deal of expertise.
He's a great chap.
He's become a real
friend of the division,
actually a colleague
already at this point.
We're really thrilled to have
him here and he's going to talk
about something that we
have all grown to love.
If you didn't love Gorey before
you'll love him after this.
So please welcome Glen.
[ Applause ]
>> Glen Emil: Thank you Mark.
Well, he already introduced
me so I can just tell you
that I started collecting
Gorey when I was
about 18 years old
so had a good time.
The challenge was actually being
18 not having a lot of income
at the time trying to find Gorey
on the cheap without the Internet,
so fortunately it wasn't
too difficult.
I think there may be one or two
spots that we need to fill in
and you can call it
a 100% collection.
Of course, there are 800 pieces
but Gorey only published about 100
and some odd of his
own original books.
He's done maybe two to
three hundred illustrations
for other publications
and periodicals.
I'll go over that.
But I just want to say thank you.
Thank you for coming.
This is really hard for me and
I really do like this place.
This is what my, I want my
library to look like this.
That's why I like it.
You let me hang out
here and this is why.
Anyway, let's go ahead and dive in.
I have a small presentation.
It's broken into two parts.
For those who don't know
Gorey's bibliography,
some of the major details about
his career I'll provide that.
I apologize.
I understand after speaking to Mark
that I'm not a professional
presenter
so I don't know how
to do this very well.
But I have text and I have
images so for those who really,
really dislike watching I'm
saying I have on the right hand
of the screen there will be
images of the entire collection
of books passing through and
to keep it interesting I have a
prize [laughter].
Like I say there's about 106
books that can you be attributed
to him directly but I've
omitted presenting the albums,
the "Amphigorey" series and
that leaves four more books
that aren't presented so if there
are any collectors out there
who actually can name three of
those four books that are missing
from this screen presentation then
I have an Edward Gorey pen from,
made by the Edward Gorey
House up in Cape Cod.
It's a very nice one.
It's almost like [inaudible] so.
It's three books.
Name the three books that don't
show outside of "Amphigorey."
>> Let's make this clear.
Three books that are in
the "Amphigorey" series
but they're not going to
be in your presentation?
>> Glen Emil: That's right.
I'm sorry, three books out
of the entire collection
that aren't shown outside of the
"Amphigorey" volumes themselves.
There are four of them.
I didn't photograph them.
So there are four individual
books of his
that he wrote that won't be shown.
So if you can think of those I think
you have the collection, right?
So before we get started
Mark brought up a good point.
I think it would be interesting
to know that along with part
of Gorey's charm is that
he's a very mysterious man.
He's as mysterious as the books that
he's written and so there's a lot
of talk, a lot of hearsay generated.
So I'm going to try to expose one
or two of these if this will let me.
It is said that Edward Gorey --
>> Glen Emil: Ah.
It is. This is what's
mysterious about it.
It's the words.
It's not the pictures.
Ah, anyway, I was saying
that did it come up?
No signal.
Okay. So as I was saying, Edward
Gorey there's a lot of legends,
a lot of myths about Edward Gorey.
One of them might be that he was
actually a child of a refugee
from the turn of the century,
Russian, a Russian czar,
left his children in England and
got stuck on a boat and came here.
Another one is that he
might have English --
he might be English and ran to
America and plied his trade here
or that he also has a very
famous mother who's a --
who happens to be either
a songstress or a dancer
or [inaudible] serious actress.
Let's see.
Let's see if we can find.
[ Video playing ]
>> Glen Emil: In the mirror was an
obviously very popular although not
many people know her name
it was Edward Gorey's mother
for 11 years maybe,
eight to 11 years.
It's not entirely clear but he was,
she and his father were divorced
when he was 11 and then he --
his father remarried and when
he was 27 years old his parents
reunited again.
So for a brief period Edward Gorey
did have a very interesting mother.
Anyway, so I explained
about the story.
I'm going to just basically --
indulge me while I
read the text portion.
The right side will show eventually
the books in Gorey's collection.
"In 1925 Edward Gorey is born
22nd in Chicago, Illinois.
He has no the siblings.
He develops a taste
for reading and drawing
and pursues creative
activities in the theater,
writing in his formative years.
By the time Gorey is five years
old he has read 'Dracula',
'Alice's Adventures in
Wonderland' by nine.
Supposedly 'Dracula' terrifies him.
In 1943 he studies at the Chicago
Art Institute for one semester.
That's his formal training.
In 1946 Edward enrolls at
Harvard University majoring
in French literature.
While there he becomes
involved with poets, theater
and Cambridge eventually befriending
John Ashbery, Frank O'Hara,
Alison Lurie and Buddy Lang.
Gorey starts shopping at the Gotham
Book Mart in Manhattan in 1946
and he meets Francis Steloff who
later agrees to help sell his books.
He also starts -- in 1952 Jason
Epstein, a friend of his takes
over at Doubleday Anchor Paperbacks
which used to be just kind
of low quality paperback
books and asks Gorey
to leave the art department.
Gorey accepts and for the next seven
years he polished his craft book
illustration, layout, typography
and the book series
was very successful."
Now there's about 60
of these book covers
and they have a very distinctive,
very beautiful touch to them.
Some collectors just collect those
books and they're hard to find some
of them because a lot of
them are just trashed,
thrown away after they're-- "In
1953 he publishes his first book,
'The Unstrung Heart' and moves
from the Boston area to Manhattan
and over time Gorey publishes
at least two books a year
until his death creating his stories
first and then illustrating them.
Gorey produces camera ready
artwork and typography and except
for the stage work he doesn't
reduce or enlarge his drawings.
1957 impressed by the ballet
under George Balanchine's guidance
Gorey embarks upon a dedicated
resolve to attend every
performance of [inaudible].
Apparently, it was true and by
1982 he had quenched his thirst
for the most ephemeral
art but he as openly said
that this is probably the
strongest influence on his style.
In 1959 he starts work as
editor and art director
at Looking Glass Library another
Epstein venture at Random House
until that closes three years later.
Gorey finds this job to be the most
satisfying because he actually got
to choose some of the stories
as well illustrate
some of the cover work.
In 1962 unable to find a publisher
for the 'Beastly Baby'
Gorey self-publishes it
under the Fantod Press name.
The Fantod Press eventually
publishes 28 of his works many
of which attract mainstream
publishers.
Besides 'The Beastly
Baby' other Gorey classics
from Fantod Press includes
the 'Chinese Obelisks',
'The Deranged Cousins',
'The Disrespectful Summons',
'The Evil Garden' which I love
very much, 'The Lost Lions',
'The Osbick Bird' and 'The Pious
Infant' and 'The Untitled Book.'
Gorey publishes the
'The Vinegar Works'
in 1963 a three volume set including
his famous, 'The Gashlycrumb Tinies'
with A is for Amy who
fell down the stairs.
His favorite job at the
Looking Glass Library folds
so he takes a designer
position at Bobbs-Merrill.
He finds this assignment difficult
so buoyed by his modest success
so far Gorey decides to
launch his free-lance program.
In 1965 Gorey's first
solo art exhibit opens
at the California College of
Arts and Crafts in Oakland
across the bridge from
San Francisco.
Although he does not attend
this exhibit he ships over 190
of his own original artworks.
Gorey also begins teaching classes
on advanced children's book
illustration at the School
of Visual Arts in Manhattan and
this lasts for one semester."
No comment.
[laughter] "In 1967 Andreas Brown,
a young antiquarian book appraiser
and bibliographer from California
buys the Gotham Book Mart
from Frances Steloff.
Already a fan of Gorey's
work, he begins actively
to promote Gorey's
art and literature
and this includes yearly
art exhibits
at Gotham's Art Gallery while
managing Gorey's publications
and building a small but growing
clientele of collectors thirsty
for Gorey's limited editions
and by this time Gorey
has published 24 books.
Mr. Brown is still involved
in the Gorey community.
He's on the -- as many of Gorey's --
were issued with fewer than
500 copies each Brown suggested
that he assemble them in
a [inaudible] collection
and that became 'Amphigorey'
in 1972.
It wins notable book of the year
awards from the New York Times
and American Institute
of Graphic Arts
and it has been in print ever since.
Many believe that this is more or
less what launched his book career."
>> You said Andreas Brown.
>> Glen Emil.
That was Andreas Brown, yeah.
In the -- quite a few years ago.
"Gorey designs in 1977, he
designs a sets and costumes
for Broadway's revival of
'Dracula' starring Frank Langella
at the Martin Beck Theatre.
The show is a huge hit
with over 900 performances
and as Gorey owns a piece
of the show it allows him
to buy a cozy home near his
family in Cape Cod [inaudible].
Gorey also wins a Tony Award for
his costume design, not stage design
but costume design and he
doesn't like that at all.
Gorey purchases his dream house,
a sea captain's home built
in 1821 in Yarmouth Port.
In 1980 Gorey is asked design
opening and closing credits
for the 'PBS Mystery' series.
He works with Canadian
broadcasting animator Derek Lamb
and he also creates the hand-drawn,
two-dimensional stage sets
prompting Vincent Price
to call it Gorey's Mansion.
From 1980 to his death Gorey
publishes forty more books,
creates over 20 small stage plays
and renders several hundred drawings
for other books, periodicals
and so on and so on."
These are great.
There's got to be at least four
to five different iterations
of this animation and originally
Gorey said his plan would have taken
somewhere along like 30
minutes of animation.
They cut it down to
just under two minutes.
"In 1980 Andreas Brown estimates
that Gorey had produced well
over 10,000 drawings
over his lifetime.
In 1983 Gorey leaves Manhattan,
moves to Cape Cod permanently.
Gorey tells people that this is
precipitated by the recent death
of Balanchine but Gorey lives
happily on the Cape with a handful
of cats until his death and Andreas
Brown is currently the co-trustee
of the Edward Gorey Trust.
They handle all the
original art work
and intellectual property rights
and so the archive he
says are just dozens
of boxes just illustrations
that Gorey never used.
He would just draw, so the estimate
of ten thousand illustrations
is conservative."
No this probably goes back
before published work but --
"On April 13, 2000 Gorey
suffers a massive heart attack
in his home while his friend
Rick Jones repairs a toaster
in the kitchen.
He's rushed to the Hyannis Hospital
but two days later he
dies from complications.
Gorey was 75 and was survived
by two cousins and a nephew.
Gorey chooses to be cremated.
Half of his ashes were set adrift
off a beach on Cape Cod Bay
by his friends and family."
>> Glen Emil: There's more.
"In 2002 Gorey's home opens to the
public as the Edward Gorey House,
a museum dedicated to
preserving his legacy.
His original artwork is
like I mention is archived
by the Edward Gorey
Charitable Trust.
His personal library of 25
thousand books is housed
at San Diego Library State
University in California.
Most of Gorey's effects were
distributed amongst his friends
and according to his will Gorey
wanted his artwork to continue
in perpetuity to benefit
animal welfare.
Before he died, Gorey and Rick
Jones were discussing funerals
and Gorey said 'just
throw me in the yard.'
So 11 years later his
friend honored his request.
Gorey's last remaining
ashes were scattered along
with his last four cats
around his property
in Yarmouth Park, Yarmouth Port."
This is one of his
plays that was performed
at the scattering of the ashes.
[ Video playing in background ]
I was at that performance and
afterwards Rick Jones told me
that they hadn't planned
on putting the picture
of Gorey up at the very end.
This was just a restaging,
supposedly just a restaging
of several of his plays.
So, thank you for sitting
through the tough part.
That was just a lot of information.
But yeah, the scattering of the
ashes was a very interesting show.
It showed that Gorey's work was
just as strong on the play side,
the whole entire community of
players, puppet players and so on,
the puppets being those little
white head figures of paper mache.
Gorey had made about 100 of those
little things about an inch or so.
So they didn't have much
detail but the second part
of the presentation is just
more or less this objective,
my opinion about what
makes Gorey so interesting.
One of the things that Gorey used
to tell people whenever people
asked him what does any of it mean
and even the person who used
to ask this question was
Andreas Brown himself
and Gorey would almost
always invariably say,
"What you see is what you get."
And I think that answer more or
less just managed to push off a lot
of people but I think when you think
about what Gorey was talking about,
what you see is what you get, what
you understand, you can take this
as what you understand is
what you can read into it.
He loved it when people
read into his work only
because it showed how
engaged people were.
He didn't divulge meanings
pretty much of any of his works.
He would say, "Read into it.
I'm happy to take whatever
you feel like,
whatever translation
you come up with."
But there are some things
that he really enjoyed.
What you're seeing here is
some of the, some old footage
of films of Louis Feuillade.
This one happens to
be from "Fantomas."
When Gorey was in Harvard
they used to watch and also
in New York they would
look for performances.
This is 100 years old.
Most of this was, this
particular one was done in 1914.
It was a series of what's
called -- the French hated it.
It wasn't supposedly the high
art of filmmaking so they had,
I forgot the name they gave it
but it wasn't a complimentary one
but Gorey truly found
something in it and I think
in a way you can actually see
some of his style being used here.
I mean this is truly
different than a lot
of silent film movies
especially the setting, the stage.
An analyst, a critic for film
had a wonderful interpretation
about the Feuillade films.
These were films that were not of
course, popular because they were --
the narration proved to
be somewhat deceptive.
Feuillade enjoyed leading
a narration
that wasn't necessarily
showing on the screen
so that oftentimes the
audience would have to come
up with their own conclusion
at the end
because it wasn't a
straightforward narration
and I think Gorey really
picked up on that style
of not knowing who's
telling the story
and what is going to
happen at the end.
It's not a very linear kind
of unless you watch it over
and over again you're not going to
know what's going to happen next.
This is the original music
that came with these.
It's very interesting.
It's very surreal and the
colors were also intentional.
Another favorite of Gorey's
was the "The Tale of Genji"
by Murasaki Shikibu and her thousand
year-old novel Gorey read and found,
read several times and just
he never became exhausted
from some of the details.
It's known that " The Tale
of Genji" uses what's known
as [foreign language spoken]
which is basically the
transient moment that's captured.
It can be captured by a
simple expression of oh,
or ah and so [foreign word] can
also be seen as the magic moments,
the breathing moment
that will pass eventually
and I think Gorey really
latched on to that as well.
He was a very sensitive man.
He was never married.
As a matter of fact, he's come out
in a couple of introduce and said
that he was asexual as his
preference but we do know
that he has had quite a few
very, very close relationships
with other people, soulmate
kind of relationships.
One of the more remarkable
ones was with Peter Neumeyer.
He had done three books with Peter
Neumeyer and the exchange of ideas
and so on that the two men shared
is truly, truly remarkable and Gorey
and Peter Neumeyer who had a
family, was raising a family
on the East Coast while teaching
was interesting enough to come up,
Peter Neumeyer had saved his
letters that he and Gorey used to go
over all these details about coming
up with these books and they talked
about art, literature and so on and
that's just absolutely fascinating.
The book that just came out
about five years ago is called
"Floating Worlds" is still
available but it if you do want
to find the kind of
thread that Gorey loves
to dwell on a lot of it's there.
>> That was "The Leathers?"
>> Glen Emil: "The
Letters" the correspondence
between Peter Neumeyer
and Edward Gorey.
Edward Gorey also had several
other friends who he had very,
very close relationships as well
but the letters obviously
are unique to Peter Neumeyer.
And ballet, of course everyone knows
that Edward Gorey loved
George Balanchine's work
at the New York City Ballet.
And a lot of that flamboyance and
freedom of the characters shows
up in his work not just the
moments of ballet, the books written
of ballet directly but
he has several characters
that truly can say reflect their
artistic freedom of ballet,
and transient moments
that ballet brings
to the stage and brings to light.
Then Gorey loved savoring some of
those and tries convey some of that
in his work, spent many hours
talking to Andreas Brown
and other collectors and
people who love Gorey
and the list of influences are huge.
They're enormous, very well-read,
loved several artists enough to say
that he wishes he could draw like
let's say like Edward R. [Inaudible]
or the drawing techniques but his
work is very unique in the sense
that he tries to convey
more than just literature.
He's a storyteller.
I think he uses whatever
medium and whatever style
that actually helps produce
the most interesting story.
If you look at the stage
settings you can almost see some
of Gorey's attention to detail,
framed and the wallpaper,
the fabric designs, the
furniture it's just --
and I love how he's
picked up on that.
He's not just imitating it.
He's in a lot of his work
he shows some of the details
that helps isolate the story.
So I think these are some of the
things that I've come up with.
I'm sure everyone, people have ideas
as well about what makes Gorey click
for them and click for other people.
He's, Gorey is interesting that a
lot of people will readily admit
that they don't understand
Gorey and I find that wonderful
that they would just
come out and say,
"I don't understand
any of this at all."
Supposedly he and Alison
Lurie, one of his early friends
from Harvard would spend, have spent
hundreds of hours watching some
of these in the vaults, not in
the vaults but in the festivals
that would show up every
once in a while in Boston,
somebody would uncover
some of these old things.
[inaudible] Yes he did, he did.
>> So you're pretty sure
that Gorey had watched these?
>> Glen Emil: Oh, without doubt,
without doubt he'd seen these.
His favorite Feuillade
films were "Barrabas."
I haven't seen "Barrabas" but
I understand it's available now
so I think it's worth
taking a look at.
But he also loved the
"Fantomas" series
and it's a very, very long series.
It's a wonderful series,
so thank you.
Thank you so much.
That's my presentation.
[ Applause ]
Does anybody have any questions
and does anybody have an idea
about which books were missing?
Yes.
>> I have no idea about the books
that are missing [inaudible]
but I'm curious.
Have you ever met him?
>> Glen Emil: Well,
I wanted to meet him.
I lived in San Francisco when I
was doing most of my collecting
so it was the choice
of either going out
and visiting Edward Gorey meant a
book or two or three, actually ten.
I also wanted to give
Gorey his space because by
that time I was collecting
in 1978 started
and by 1990 I think
most people understood
that Gorey was constantly approached
by his fans who would just come up
and just to stand with him and that
would be it but and I didn't want
to be so intrusive, so I decided
just to be happy with his output
and just kind of imagine the rest.
After he passed away I
became as a collector
and after putting my
collection online and it's more
or less a portal that allows people
to explore Gorey growth a little
bit not just from one side
but from plays and from books
and from around the world Gorey,
there's Gorey collectors from around
the world who have sites as well.
They have interesting things that
they've put up so I create links
as well as a bibliography
of his main works.
I'm sorry, you had,
there was a -- yes.
>> What made you decide to donate
your collection to the Library?
>> Glen Emil: Well, I wanted
to find a much better home.
My collection after dragging it from
California to here the humidity,
the weather and so on I just,
I could watch it withering
away, the edges of the pages.
The pages were turning colors and
I just, it was breaking my heart
and I just wanted it to actually
be preserved in one piece
because it's a remarkable
amount of energy to put together
and so I think it came up
somebody had knew somebody
who visited the Edward Gorey House.
I'm a member of the board
of the Edward Gorey House
so I get some information of some
of the travelers and the head
of your poetry department had come
to the Gorey House a few years ago
and that came up and we,
a few thoughts came around
and I thought you know this
would be a perfect place
for Edward Gorey to be.
>> Have you kept back anything?
[laughter]
>> Glen Emil: Should I tell him?
>> Any particular treasure?
>> Glen Emil: Actually there is one
and it's got a very Goreysque
kind of almost ending.
He has, Gorey loved to make
these little stuffed dolls
which you'll look at
these things a little bit.
Just last week one of
the treasures I decided
to keep it was a Figbash
doll, very, very long arms.
I guess there's nothing
like it here,
anyway it was filled with rice.
So you can imagine what
rice sounds like to a mouse
and unfortunately I thought it was a
very unsafe place and just a couple
of weeks ago I opened it up and lo
and behold mice had been
munching on Figbash's.
But I have to say it
really doesn't bother me
because at this point
I think the bulk
of the collection is
safe now from mice.
It was kind of Goreyesque,
apparently Gorey loved
animals and I can see why.
If we had a very valuable piece
here and nature comes along decides
to do natural things to it.
It didn't bother me.
It should bother me but it doesn't.
Yes.
>> Can you tell us something
about poster here, the
green covers, books?
>> Glen Emil: Ah, well, these two --
are you talking about the
second, the first one?
Oh, this one here.
>> Yeah.
>> Glen Emil.
This would be a what they
call a bus size advertisement
for "Mystery", the TV series.
So he did the animation and he would
create these large advertisements
posters to be used in public
spaces like bus stops and so on.
So this is probably the largest.
I mean Gorey draws to
scale so this is his work.
This is a good one actually
to look at the details.
When you get a chance
I'll let you look
around because I'm sure you're
really here for the books.
There's a lot of fascinating,
mostly natural/super natural
little hints running all
over these, the artwork itself.
This is an excellent example.
This is the second poster is from
the same series but it just takes,
it looks like the animation.
So this one was yes, I think he
tries to capture some of the stories
that were being told in this series.
I don't know which ones
were Agatha Christie's or
but he was an enormous fan of
Agatha Christie as everyone knows.
Possibly we have people like to
call Edward Gorey's work macabre.
If you think about no one calls
Agatha Christie macabre so.
>> But he didn't do any
of her covers did he?
>> Glen Emil: For Agatha Christie?
You know that's interesting,
no not that I know of.
Some of his favorite
works he would have loved
to become involved in but he didn't.
I think he was waiting
for someone to ask.
That's more or less what happened.
Most of Gorey's artwork was produced
by somebody who just would come up
and say okay, we think you
can do this and he'd say okay.
He was very amiable
to doing whatever.
I get this first hand
from Andreas Brown.
Andreas and I are good friends and
he's told me a lot about Gorey.
I hope somebody actually walks
up to Andreas and follows him
around and tape records him.
He knows the story that's not
in print about Edward Gorey.
Maybe I can drag him
down here one day.
>> I'm going to stop the
questions there if we can.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.